pfff
[Applaudissements]
crier ton nom à tous cette demoiselle
qui seront d ie 6 ans quand je passerai
devant m je veux crier ton grillé forme
en compagnie des mines amour aussi fort
cris et on a tous deux maps
qui suivent les boulevards ans aimant
tout temps
[Musique]
dont deux cherchant partout qu'on me
prête je veux crier ton
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comme lady
[Musique]
ton nom à tous ceux qui suivent
en somme en tout temps
ton nom de cheikh samba do
[Musique]
je veux crier ton nom ton
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je soutiens du colonel amos pitallier
s'était pas fait pour déplaire
et
elle était belle on voulait
regardez les deux camps et enfants et
encore il aurait pu danser l'aja les
chouettes les prix
[Applaudissements]
cet effet tous pris samedi fait et on
avait tout simplement elle avait qu'un
seul défaut
elle souligne qu'il faut
[Musique]
l'ue tente à verser le masseur très vite
elle premiers baigneurs à l'attaqué du
côté de son cas en deçà dans de sages
[Musique]
en douceur et pourfendre faisait
d'échecs répétés savait qu'il fallait
[Musique]
louis ou pas pendant cette news vous
propose de partager la vie
les décors vallée tél je commençais à
m'inquiéter
je tolère et cheveux longs d'un kop
sinon elle devenait malaise un beau jour
j'en ai eu marre c'est épique que la mer
à boire
si leur fils est un hélico j'ai nagé
vers d'autres zones saines
10h11 et des chemises et bradl
[Musique]
j'étais très triste
géniteur est là et valhalla
[Applaudissements]
halal
ah la la
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
si je t'oublie pas dans le jour
[Musique]
je passe une irm odile et
dp
d'école
il se retire
j'ai là
vide et le carlo
lou
la nuit qui m'apparaissent immense
[Musique]
je tend les bras et de saisir
mais tu prends un malin
[Musique]
m
a toujours aidé
mais elle sait
la nuit
j'aime
[Musique]
oui
je verrai
[Musique]
et puis ton rire phone web
il ne sait plus d'où chercher
[Musique]
quand tout ce thème revient l'espoir
et je me repose
ce qui m'a bien
l'igas et
et tu m'appelles me larguer
[Musique]
mais chaque fois au sein de glace
tous rire niais tout est passé
[Musique]
gervais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
j'avais
le jour des scripts en images
et tu repars je ne sais où
et
houle est celui qui te tient tant qu
algérie
[Musique]
celui qui veut
c
je devais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
gérer
oh
sow
[Musique]
déjà les filles sèment rachat pour
quelques années
ben on s'y attache elle est partie
elle a présidée
bagages
et puis la vie tourne là bas
je l étais belle pourtant
[Musique]
si j'avais pu la gagner
oh
le soir comme une offense
[Musique]
moi je l'aurais
merci
il est parti
[Musique]
après dell
tu veux lui dire soyons son bord le togo
tél
[Musique]
et
l'amour est lent
à s'installer on ne prend pas le temps
de s'inviter parfois penser
pauvre flanché on sert des temps il faut
tout oublier
[Musique]
elle était belle
pourtant
[Musique]
si j'avais pu la garder
le soir comme il enfin
ouah je ré blessés
[Musique]
il est parti
hop
c'est la faute
après rennes
tu veux que les oiseaux s'envolent tôt
leurs terres elle était belle c'est
drôle je l'oubli déjà je te comprends
vatin ne te retourne pas
[Applaudissements]
non
alors les copains
6 heures
de tout temps des mois
et puis
sur les ponts vos regards ce froid
qu'il me désarmé m'accable
aussi de je-ne-sais-quoi
coupable
on cherche
tom
sa gauche mois ci suivie
au mam nay le gars mais se dit en état
sous tous les planches c'est vrai j'ai
de l'argent
elle se lave auto
au prochain
chacun
2 1
comme toujours
[Applaudissements]
alors des couples
je suis un autre pour m'habille ces
machins
j'essaie toujours des mots avant de
terre
les scènes et les studios j'évolue
livrés
les
bistrot
touba
[Musique]
rendez vous où je vais me
airtel de trouver là de vous mais chacun
son
40e
comme toujours
[Musique]
quinze jours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
soit pas fâché si j'étais chanter
souvenir d'eux
mais quinze ans
ne boude pas si tu es absent de berre et
brident 1 2 les sommes
c'est à moi
était insignifiante ont préparé un gosse
tabou
et c'est pourquoi je te les chante
elle est présente
tour à tour oui c'est pourquoi
je te les chante mais les présentent
tour à tour
mais ce
assure t on
je ne fais pas ses yeux furie ben oui tu
l'auras
chez tu seras ma dernière
dans chaque fille que j'ai connu c'est
un photo ac
je cherchais
[Musique]
oui quand dans mes bras je t'ai tenue
moi je tremblais je le comprenais
[Musique]
que tu es sorti d'une fable pour venir
habiter en retz
et ce serait bien regrettable que notre
amour
ainsi sachez oui ce serait
[Applaudissements]
que notre amour ainsi cette chaîne
semaine
je t'aime
je ne sais pas
à ses yeux
furibond oui tu l'auras
tu seras
de la chanson
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est pas sérieux
oui
je tue sa dernière chanson
[Applaudissements]
à
bah
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
là
[Musique]
j'ai vu lorient dans son écrin
avec la lime pour bagnères et je
comptais en tout cas d'à
chantier au monde ses lumières
[Musique]
mais quand j'ai vu j'ai raison
que
[Musique]
je sais
les géantes
[Musique]
pan sur les jeunes
en chine je ne vois tu pas de chapelle
deux mois qui nous
paix
sur la tête que nice où elle cache
misère
c'est le tout de même
danger
faut-il y est
[Musique]
le sénat
du tout
magali
[Musique]
inch'allah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je
ils olivier pleure son gant sa tendre
épouse se baigner
sur les dépenses
prisonnier l'inter
ennemi
[Musique]
on
sur une épine de barbelés
m
larose
les gens 106 m
et vous
si chose
[Musique]
10e de l'enfer
c'est
[Musique]
péchalat
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
des cheveux
comment
fameux temps
sous l'orage
le sang
une vie
tout à fait
le courage
une femme tous
le monde devait
mais oui j'ai vu jérusalem coquelicot
sur 1
le chien j'entends
ce requiem
lorsque sûr je suis
[Musique]
et puis elle beau
dames
ou pas
demain
les petits mots
vva
[Musique]
là
inch'allah
[Applaudissements]
je
[Musique]
inch'allah
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
sur le quai d'une gare au bout de moi
mais moi un tableur ou petit joue à la
demeure bien trop court
[Musique]
nous n'avons jamais parlé d'amour ou
sous de la tendance nous pallions
vous avez qui veut s
en obtenant
notre mémoire
elle d'elle mais moi de moi
ne vous gêne
parler de nous
non
ne vont jamais allé
c'est bien
on sourit
ouais
et y
bon
mais m
m
[Musique]
j'avais pas
je n'ai jamais
[Musique]
voici
ma solitude massane habitudes
qui se dressent
[Musique]
moi
[Applaudissements]
au prochain je ne sais quoi
[Musique]
je n'ai pourtant pas parler
non
jamais
[Musique]
ris de veau
je veux jeu
dit ça
que
[Musique]
là
or
[Musique]
là
je ne sais
[Musique]